know the answer that is no Alec Baldwin
had no idea his SNL Trump stint was
gonna last this long and neither did his
wife hilarya when I go to SNL I go there
and I get a cup of coffee and he has a
his own dressing room and then I sleep
on this really like nasty couch with my
coat on top of me and I'll wake up for
his part and then I fall asleep the rest
time because I have a million children
so he's in a very glamorous public
library we're not shelter for the
homeless
et spoke with Baldwin at the red carpet
premiere of his new movie the public
where he dished on his character and why
he chose to do the film this is a guy
that comes into this situation it's very
simple these people are breaking the law
yeah he's got a job to do he wants to
try to make sure as two people are heard
as possible because he's a crisis
negotiator but at the same time there's
the backstory about his son I don't want
to give too much away but it does
definitely humanizes him and complicate
the story you know Emilia was somebody
who everyone in the business loves and
admires Emilio and it goes beyond him
being a nice guy and a guy with fur you
know low ego it's important everybody
wants to make films like this they want
to go do things where they make money
and they make a good living as best as
they can but in terms of injecting some
kind of quality
it's a better more thoughtful films in
your career when this guy calls you if
you're free you go no no it's not about
money or getting paid or what-have-you
you really just want to make one of his
films because he's such a really great
not just actor and director and producer
but writer
the script was a very smart script and
that's what made me want to become
Baldwin also detailed why the project
was so close to his heart one thing that
I think is gonna be the result of this
film as people as I hope a critical mass
of people will be unable to drive by a
library again and I realize what's
really going on in there your attitude
about what a library is has changed and
you learn my wife and I have a
charitable foundation and we funded our
local library and he stepped on Long
Island there was a big push to build a
children's wing then we found out from
an article in The New York Times that
there was a little little triptych of
three libraries in Iowa and we called
them and we said you know how can we
help you and you know what's your
mission and what do you need and they
named it a pretty modest amount of money
they wanted and I said do you want it
for books or what do you want it for for
you know internet material computers
which is no we need it for food because
the kids come here and they and they're
undernourished and they're hungry and
they expect to skim a juice box and a
snack
we were just knocked out just couldn't
believe
so librarians today as Emilia which
teaches you in this movie are crisis
counselors there their mental health
counselors they're homeless counselors
they're not just dispensing books and
intranet material they're dealing with
the needs of the community on the most
complicated level I think this movie
really really makes that clear enough
Parker this no no no wait don't tell me
let me guess
Joey Monica Ross Rachel and I'm sorry
Phoebe didn't mention you the 60 year
old actor also reflected on working with
Lisa Kudrow on friends 25 years ago I
remember when I did that show I arrived
there on a Tuesday and on Friday they
had all signed deals for that season as
a million dollars in episode they
announced it that Monday and I should
have for work on Tuesday so all of them
had a lot on their mind they were all of
it preoccupied but the person who I had
all my scenes with who was just an angel
was Lisa Kudrow I love this occasion and
I always dream about working with her
again so apprec is really very unique
actress and I'm great I'm with you and
I'm with you what a great time to be
alive
you